ماذا عن أسعار الغاز لأن أسعار الغاز في بعض الأحيان
تتعلق بمبادرة السياسة الخارجية التي
تتعلق بشيء يتجاوز
تكلفة الغاز ونحن حوالي 330 جالونًا في
معظم الأماكن التي الآن عندما ترتفع
من أسفل في خانة واحدة ،
أعني دولارًا
زائد واه وهذا بسبب
حجب الإمدادات من
قبل أوبك ولذا هناك الكثير من
المفاوضات
هناك هناك الكثير من الناس في الشرق الأوسط
يريدون التحدث معي
لست متأكدًا من أنني سأتحدث معهم
ولكن  النقطة هي أن الأمر يتعلق
بإنتاج الغاز ، فهناك أشياء يمكننا القيام بها
في هذه الأثناء ، هل تعتقد أن هناك ذكاءً ،
يعني هل ترى هل لديك جدول زمني
لأسعار الغاز عندما تعتقد أنها قد
تبدأ في النزول ،
أعتقد أنك ستبدأ في رؤية الغاز
تنخفض الأسعار
مع اقترابنا من دخول فصل الشتاء ،
أعني ، أعذرني في العام المقبل في عام 2022 ،
لا أرى أي شيء
سيحدث في هذه الأثناء سيؤدي
إلى خفض أسعار الغاز بشكل كبير ،
لكن الأمر سيكون صعبًا.  أن
يكون صعبًا مثل أ  إمكانية أن تكون قادرًا
على خفضه يعتمد
قليلاً على المملكة العربية السعودية وبعض
الأشياء الأخرى الموجودة
في المكتب